voilà pour ce documentaire éclairante
pauline frachon et jean-yves cochard
alors comment favoriser le retour à
l'emploi c'est cabinet de reclassement
sont ils une bonne solution peut-on
généraliser ce dispositif
particulièrement personnalisée et plus
largement pôle emploi utile un acteur
efficace comment réformer ce marché
comment faut-il toucher au code du
travail au salaire minimum à la durée
légale quels sont les freins de ce
sacro-saint retour à l'emploi réagissez
sur le hashtag docu débat et pour en
débattre j'accueille caroline cayeux
bonjour jour vous êtes sénatrice les
républicains de l'oise et secrétaire
national au travail et à l'emploi et
surtout maire de beauvais merci merci
d'être avec nous gérard filoche bonjour
on ne vous présente plus anciens
secrétaires anciens pardon inspecteur du
travail et membre du bureau national du
parti socialiste
merci d'être avec nous
hervé chapron vous êtes l'ancien
directeur général adjoint de pôle emploi
à hauteur de pôle emploi autopsie d'un
naufrage c'est l'humain bienvenus et je
me tourne vers pauline frachon bonjour
vous êtes la réalisatrice de ce
documentaire la lutte des cadres pauline
qu'est ce qui vous a donné l'idée de ce
documentaire
alors en fait mon père a été licencié
il ya quelques années il avait 59 ans
donc ça a été un coup dur et il s'est
retrouvé accompagner dans un de ces
cabinets d'ie doubt placement donc dont
je ne connaissais pas l'existence
auparavant et il commençait à me
raconter un peu ces journées lé rendez
vous avec son coach des ateliers
collectifs auxquels il participait je
trouvais ça très étonnant ce qui se
tramait dans ces entreprises privées et
du coup ça m'a donné envie d'en faire un
un documentaire de société pour parler
plus largement du monde du travail et
qu'est ce qui vous a le plus marqué dans
ces cabinets ce qui m'a frappé c'était
le lien quand même qui se crée entre les
candidats le soutien qu'ils apportaient
mutuellement évidemment ils sont
regroupés dans une entreprise de
transition comme ça et ils ont la chance
de pouvoir partager du coup se faire un
réseau être accompagné les ateliers
collectifs évidemment ont un petit peu
interpellé qu'on leur réapprennent à
s'habiller à avoir une bonne posture à
parler alors que ce sont des cadres qui
sont très expérimentés qui ont passé
l'âge peut-être de se faire donner ce
genre de conseils mais visiblement c'est
la règle du jeu à jouer et ça m'a assez
interpellé qu'est ce que vous avez pensé
de ce documentaire
connu bien on vous que du bien parce
qu'ils montrent et aussi par les ja lire
entre les lignes entre les lignes on
s'aperçoit d'abord que
les candidats au retour à l'emploi
sont des cadres
qui quand vous les écoutez vous dise moi
j'ai bien fait mon travail ça m'est
tombé dessus du jour au lendemain j'ai
rien vu venir chez vous cherchez
mais faute je ne les vois pas et
pourtant je suis là et pourtant je
galère oui parce que ce qu'on voit bien
pauline dans votre documentaire c'est
que la particularité de cette population
de cadres c'est que souvent c'est un
changement de stratégie de l'entreprise
qui les conduit à être licenciés donc
c'est assez particulier en fait comme
vous avez eu des difficultés à rentrer
dans ces structures oui on a mis du
temps quand même à trouver une
entreprise qui accepte de vraiment jouer
le jeu c'est à dire de nous laisser
en toute liberté et
assistez au rendez-vous qui sont quand
même assez confidentielle avec le coach
vous atelier collectif avait beaucoup de
cadres qui refusé d'être filmé c'est un
monde quand même assez fermé on a mis du
temps à trouver la bonne société qui
nous laisse libres de faire ce qu'on
voulait faire mais une fois qu'ils ont
dit oui ça a été
gérard filoche qu'est ce que vous pensez
de ces cabinets puis la plus largement
de ce que vous avez pu voir peut-être en
termes humains écoutez on soumet les
gens à des pentes minuh humiliante tout
ça parce que il n'ya pas de carnet de
commandes pour les entreprises donc
après tout ceux qui sont placés dans
cette situation dramatique d'être
chassées de leur emploi et d'avoir tant
de difficultés en retrouver sont
victimes d'un système économique pervers
donc il faut aller à l'origine c'est ça
qui m'intéresse parce que tout ça c'est
occupationnel après on manipule les gens
les faits à temps et en effet faire
toute une série de rites qui si on les
regardait dans quelques années nous
sembleraient humilie ans tousse tousse
après on a vu pire comme mobilisation
d'aller faire de la randonnée
un certain âge de se trouvait placé dans
une situation où vous avez beaucoup
bossé vous avez des compétences
l'expérience et au programme un gamin
tout à fait d'accord
pour essayer de quoi déplaire au futur
taulier j'ai dit ollier pardon me laisse
aller je suis tout à fait d'accord et
moi je suis partie d'un au départ d'un
postulat où je me suis dit c'est très
humiliant très infantilisant et comment
peuvent-ils accepter de jouer ce jeu-là
ce qui est parfois ils ont pas le choix
même temps il préfère ça plutôt que on
va en reparler après que d'être à pôle
emploi
peut accompagner parce qu'il n'y a pas
de moyens parce qu'à pas de temps parce
qu'il n'ya pas il n'y a pas de lien qui
est créé avec les autres candidats c'est
toujours bien non il ya toujours pire
mais ils ne vivent pas de manière aussi
humiliante que ça en fait et ça moi ça
m'a frappé c'est en étant avec eux
pendant neuf mois que j'ai pu le
comprendre ils le vivent pas comme ça je
comprends bien d'autres films c'était
que je crois que c'est dans une boîte
d'assurance ils étaient 15 convoqua égal
de l'emploi c'est ça les éoliennes avec
deux qui étaient pris à la fin il y
avait pendant deux jours espèce de
concurrence à celui qui allait être le
plus performant le plus poli le plus
habile au pq si on fait le plus bête
pour pouvoir faire pour pouvoir pan de
l'emploi et je sais nous savons que ça
existe aussi alors où on met à l'antenne
en ce moment une émission de télé
réalité pour un cd effectivement c'est
un petit peu car audio sur ces cabinets
de reclassement est ce que pour vous moi
je pense qu'il faut tout faire pour
aider quelqu'un qui est au chômage et je
pense que il y à pôle emploi il ya aussi
comme dans ma ville la maison de
l'emploi et de la formation qui peut
être quelquefois personnalise un peu
plus les contacts un réseau je dirais
avec les entreprises locales ou
départementales qui permet de travailler
en partenariat avec pôle emploi mais moi
je pars du principe que conçoit cadre
qu'on soit ouvrier il faut tout faire
pour aider ces personnes quelquefois
changer de métier il y à des évolutions
qui peuvent être faites des propositions
des formations alors je dirais pas j'ai
à dire d'une manière aussi sévère que
monsieur filoche mais quelque part ça
m'étonne pas
que ça allait dire tout ça c'est pour le
taulier je dirais que c'est pour le bien
de chacun et je crois que c'est très
important dans ces moments de détresse
et de difficultés que rencontrent les
gens qui ont un licenciement
malheureusement j'ai eu ces expériences
j'ai vu ces expériences là certains
grâce à ces cabinets grâce à pôle emploi
mais hors de forme la formation créé
leur entreprise
donc je pense qu'il faut négliger aucune
piste
moi je crois quand même qu'il faut pas
pour répondre un peu à monsieur filage
qu'il faut pas
tout confondre je veux dire par là la
situation économique est ce qu'elle est
on ne peut que le déplorer c'est un des
résultats de la mondialisation où on est
passé dans un monde de la finance ou les
actionnaires jouent au monopoly il n'en
demeure pas moins vrai que quand je vois
le documentaire
je vais être provocateur à mon tour
peut-être pas autant que vous monsieur
fils h mais je vais essayer quand même
de vous rejoindre sur ce terrain moi je
préfère si j'étais dans une situation de
demandeur d'emploi
être dans la situation qui est décrite
dans le documentaire c'est à dire entre
lee mais c'est là où je suis provocateur
est volontairement provocateur
privilégiés par rapport à le smicard qui
va tout simple qui est dans le monde
rural qui va tout simplement aller
s'inscrire comme tout le monde toucher
ses indemnités et qui en termes
d'accompagnement ne va pas avoir ce
coaching là croyez le bien et je ne mets
pas en cause la bonne volonté de
l'ensemble pôle emploi dont on pourra
parler on y va donc quand vous disiez 4%
mais là on voit entre guillemets je vais
pas commencer mon numéro sur le
privilège enfin des gens et ils ont tout
pour
regagner le terrain de l'emploi registre
à orner c'est qu'ils réussissent à avoir
un job ou de 7 8 mois alors que la
moyenne maintenant c'est passé un an
alors justement là vous ne faites une
transition rêver je vais remercier paul
illustrations qui nous a donné quelques
détails sur son sur son documentaire
justement je voudrais qu'on réécoute
quelqu'un qui était justement pris en
charge dans ce cabinet qui nous
expliquer la différence entre pôle
emploi et lahoud classment
place que c'est peut-être est certaine
façon pour les entreprises de se
déculpabiliser non moi je vais pas dire
que je le vis pas comme ça pour les
grandes entreprises c'est effectivement
beaucoup plus facile de proposer des
indemnités de départ de transactions à
leurs collaborateurs cadres dès lors
qu'ils collent plus dans l'entreprise la
politique ou ma stratégie
ce que je vois surtout aujourd'hui c'est
mon intérêt personnel parce que ça
m'apporte et puisque ça va m'apporter
demain
fin juillet l'agencé pôle emploi
c'est c'est quelque chose qui peut même
déjà complètement différente c'est que
j'y vais
avec ma carte pour l'emploi
en avec l'étiquette chômeurs quoi donc
c'est quelque chose qui ne colle pas
trop à la peau je suis quand même
quelqu'un d'actif je vais
je vais au cabinet
c'est complètement différent je pense
que déjà ça se voit peut-être sur ma
tête le souhait n'est pas le même
et je suis candidat
un futur post je suis je suis dans la
mouvance c'est ça et nous accueillons
pascal de longeville
vous êtes associé du cabinet et aux
dirigeants qui est un cabinet donc de
reclassement out placement comme lieu de
conseil aux évolutions professionnelles
plus communément appelée seront d'accord
alors je vais ma première question
s'adresse à vous quand on entend ce
monsieur qui est pris en charge est-ce
que vos cabinets s'adresse exclusivement
à des gens qui sont cadres oui
ça se dresse ed4 ça s'adresse
exclusivement a déclaré djibo des cas on
a bien pourtant les solutions de
reclassement qui ont été votées qui sont
pour des gens qui sont dans le cadre de
plan social fin de plan de sauvegarde de
l'emploi fin c'est pas la même chose
c'est pas la même chose vous avez des
cabinets qui accompagnent des plans
sociaux et puis vous avez des cabinets
comme les nôtres qui a qu'on nous
accompagnons des cadres dans le cadre de
rupture individuel d'accord donc là en
fait c'est un deal entre l'entreprise
qui licencie un de ses cadres qui lui
paye finalement un coaching spécifique
voilà licenciements ou ruptures
conventionnelles d'accord
là on voit bien qu'il ya une forme de
privilège
donc à ce qu'on pourrait dire et ça je
me tournais j'apprends que une forme
finalement de système à deux vitesses
entre ceux qui sont pris en charge par
ces cabinets doubt placement et ceux qui
sont pris en charge par pôle emploi
alors oui mais faut aller même plus loin
que ça puisque sur le plan stratégique
de pôle emploi vous avez trois modalités
d'accompagnement si vous voulez le pôle
emploi se concentre
c'est même un peu le slogan du du plan
stratégique sur faisons plus pour ceux
qui en ont plus besoin si vous voulez ce
type de cadre que l'on voit dans le
documentaire cadres dirigeants plutôt
commun ce sont plutôt des cadres
dirigeants absolument donc ils sont dans
un accompagnement ou de suivi ces terres
qui sont comme le pôle emploi considère
qu'ils sont proches de l'emploi pôle
emploi fait moins que ce que pour ceux
qui sont très éloignées l'emploi et donc
comment dirais-je ce type de cabinet
prend j'allais dire les demandeurs
d'emploi proche très proche de l'emploi
que vous êtes leur donne encore la luz
un accompagnement qui n'a rien à voir
avec celui de prêts en cours à la spa
une des questions que pose le
documentaire c'est qu'à ce qu'on appelle
accompagner un demandeur n'a alors cessé
tard il alors qu'est ce que c'est d'être
proches ou éloignés de l'emploi
quand vous êtes éloigné l'envoi ça veut
dire qu'il ya eu une rupture dans la vie
professionnelle qui a dû qui dure depuis
un certain temps donc c'est le chômeur
de longue durée c'est pour ça que j'ai à
dire les collectivités les maisons de
l'emploi et de la formation participe
avec des chantiers de réinsertion avec
des réunions et je crois qu'on les mène
presque comme celles qui sont
faites pour les cadres que j'allais vous
dira pas donc non on voit que jamais
simplement cette offre que vous avez
l'air de qualifier de privilégiés mais
sachez que il y a dans nos collectivités
une recherche presque quotidiennes
d'accompagnement et des dalles emplois
pour les jeunes avec les et les plis
avec un certain nombre de dispositifs
ce sont des structures qui s'occupent
durant l'intervention oui voilà le
retour au travail parlait par l'as
hersoise fait son petit via
l'instant pour être clair vis-à-vis nos
téléspectateurs il existe en fait
notamment pour les publics qui sont en
réinsertion ou très éloignées de
l'emploi ce même type d'accompagnement
via des prises en charge par des
comédiens des ateliers de telle sorte en
fait à ce qui est une reprise de
confiance en soi qui peut nous permettre
de revenir là l'information d'un certain
temps des ongles juristes des choix et
même pôle emploi fait les ateliers les
bénévoles emploie d'ailleurs je fais les
choses opérateurs privés de placement
mais ce qu'il faut quand même savoir
puisque c'est dit dans le documentaire
c'est que un accompagnement
que l'on voit se dérouler là c'est 28
mille roches ou quoi
alors que par tête de pipe enfin c'est
ce qui est dit dans le documentaire est
un opérateur privé de placement c'est à
dire pôle emploi mandate une société
pour s'occuper pour accompagner le mans
dans l'emploi c'est de l'ordre de 4000
euros donc on n'est pas du tout dans le
même temps les mêmes rapports donc on
peut plus avoir le même accompagnement
c'est pas la loi d'accompagnement seul à
dire excusez moi je rectifie un petit
peu c'est à peu près un mois et demi de
salaire chargé de deux mois de salaire
ce sont les coûts des prestations
évidemment aussi si vous avez
100 kg
moi je cite le chiffre qui est là mais
si on est à 5000 euros par mois voilà
vous faites le calcul
deux poids deux mesures dans la prise en
charge d
des chômeurs
et j'ai un souci à l'épaule emploi c'est
pas de la faute nos agents ils sont
tellement peu nombreux enfin en gros je
me suis laissé dire qu'un agent avait un
portefeuille comme on dit c'est drôle
comme expression un portefeuille de 120
personnes
mais c'est directement lié on vire était
temps en temps on vend de la
flexisécurité j'espère qu'on le fera
policière mais au danemark par exemple
ils ont un agent de leurs équivalentes
pour l'emploi pour 15 16 ou 17 personnes
dont 15 le suivi il n'y a pas besoin de
passer par des cabinets privés comme ça
le suivi à l'adresser à tous est
infiniment plus d'importance oui mais à
partir du moment où effectivement vous
avez des cadres comme ça dirigeants est
ce que c'est étonnant de pouvoir
imaginer qu'ils puissent être pris en
charge de manière décorrélé de pôle
emploi sachant que c'est comme on le
disait à l'intérieur ce sont des gens
qui sont les plus proches de l'emploi en
s'étonnant que l'ouvrier l'employé ne
bénéficient pas exactement de la même
chose il ya l'expression proches de
l'emploi excuse moi puisque dans les
tous dans les vocabulaires qu'est ce que
c'est des proches loin
vous êtes proche s'il ya des mesures qui
décident de faire des embauches par
exemple dans les hôpitaux il nous manque
22 mille postes si le gouvernement
décidait de faire 22000 posant les
hôpitaux dont on a besoin au lieu d'en
supprimer 22000 d'un seul coup je
connais 22000 personnes qui seraient
proches de l'emploi n'avait pas mis les
35 heures dans l'hôpital là ce filon et
revient
justement au contraire les 35 heures
nécessité d'embaucher davantage et donc
si les gens vont travailler 50 heures il
y aurait moins besoin d'empocher donc
c'est lié à la durée du travail c'est
vrai la raison mais en vérité j'ai
revient sur l'idée que
il ya des décisions politiques
d'ailleurs tout ça qu'ils sont beaucoup
plus importants que les personnes je
suis comme tout le monde le sait chaque
fois ému intéressé à chaque cas
individuel mais je sais trop bien ce
qu'il ya derrière et quand on sait trop
bien ce qu'il ya derrière aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il ya pas de lutte contre le
chômage il y avait une lutte contre le
chômage de masse on partagera le travail
oui est ce que là les gens
un peu de déplacements comment vous
dites là et on va leur donner un petit
peu de suivi mais pas assez tout ça
c'est un peu une
cautère sur une jambe de bois c'est
comme ça que tel sur les genevois pascal
oui effectivement moi je voudrais
revenir sur ce qui fait qu'une
entreprise va considérer que un cadre
nécessite d'être pris en charge par un
cabinet d'avocats placement comme le
vôtre comment se fait ce choix alors
écoutez a aujourd'hui
dans une majorité des cas c'est à
l'initiative
du collaborateur du cadre dirigeant à
dire j'ai besoin de ça quand il discute
de son départ c'est un petit peu moins
les entreprises qu'avant
c'est eux c'est ce qu'ils demandent
d'ailleurs j'avais une chose sur ce qui
été dit précédemment ils sont tous
volontaires pour suivre un programme
et rien n'est fait utiliser on est dans
une histoire sérieuse et alors du coup
moi je me pose une autre question
là-dessus quel a été le principe qui a
permis
la naissance de ces opérateurs privés
c'est ça opérateurs privés de placement
est ce que l'idée c'était d'accélérer le
retour à l'emploi puisque vous nous
donniez des chiffres tout à l'heure et
donc de réduire la durée d'indemnisation
c'était juste de décharger les agences
pour l'emploi non au départ c'était de
réduire
de réduire la durée d'indemnisation
un seul chiffre quand même sur
l'indemnisation
aujourd'hui l'assurance chômage à un
déficit de 22 proche entre 24 et 25
milliards d'euros
imaginez combien de temps il va falloir
pour mettre les compteurs à zéro c'est
de l'ordre du quasi impossible c'est à
dire que comme on ne voit pas le pôle
emploi si ce n'est dans des rêves je ne
vois pas comment l'équilibré du régime
d'assurance chômage pourrait revenir
rapidement
donc c'est donc tout être pas tout une
bonne partie des mesures de ces dix
dernières années a été pour réduire la
durée de chômage et réduire ce déficit
qui est très très coûteux et il y a eu
ce qu'on appelle les dépenses active
c'est à dire que par exemple l'assurance
chômage
lorsque il y avait là une peu avant
fusion a commencé sur ses propres
deniers à faire des formations pour que
les demandeurs d'emploi forme et
retrouve plus rapidement le chemin de
l'emploi et donc la durée
d'indemnisation est baissée l'objectif
était de 21 jours mais ça chiffre en
millions à l'arrivée obtenu nombreux
demandeurs d'emploi il y a eu par
exemple ce qu'on appelle les opérateurs
privés de placement c'est à dire des
grands cabinets qui ont créé
j'allais livre ou en interne ou par
filialisation des cabinets qui les ont
des vingt six ans à un moment il n'était
pas aussi question que les agences
d'intérim de vienne
absolument il y a des les les grandes
l'intérim ont fait ça exactement et ont
ce genre de cabinet qui n'est pas aussi
performant aussi
fini que ça et qui je coûte pour un
demandeur d'emploi 4 à 5000 euros alors
caroline cayeux c'est quand même un
énorme business c'est un marché
absolument monstrueux finalement qu'on a
créé aussi pour cette agence
moi je dirais pas tout à fait ça on l'a
pas créés ils se sont créés on a onze
verdier
j'avoue répondu aux
besoins créés par l'opérateur public
ils se sont
aussi créés parce qu'il y avait un
besoin et un besoin vertueux quand la
personne diminué par deux son délai de
chômage c'est autant pour son moral pour
ce pour ses besoins économiques sade et
ce seront des gens qui seront indemnisés
moins longtemps ou pôle emploi et ont
classé
tout le monde est gagnant
c'est pas d'accord enfin surtout ce
qu'organise le business
quand les gens revivra durée de chômage
de 6,2 6,7 bois c'est dur le chômage me
suis laissé gagner par exemple le pour
votre cabinet donc c est aux dirigeants
sarko jour nos deux pays oui david et
entend par là mais bien sûr vous donnez
vous trouverez des rations ça n'arrivera
pas votre rémunération mais le chiffre
d'affaires d'une entreprise comme la
vois tu sais combien ont écouté un
cabinet comme le notait on peut lire et
à peu près 750 à 800 milles roues et es
et combien nous sommes très peu
d'acteurs en france à faire ça très peu
moins de 20 ouais donc le tout qui
présente nous a pas du tout
marché que ça peut représenter
bon écoutez c'est pas grave le chiffre
d'affaires global c'est pas facile à
cerner passe maintenant j'ai l'âge des
cabinets aussi qui sont diversifiées
inquiets ou d'autres activités alors il
ya de toute façon la question qui se
pose ici set quand même l'efficacité de
pôle emploi et s'étaient pointés par
toujours l'une des personnes que l'on a
suivi dans ce documentaire je suis allée
maximum 30 personnes ça peut arriver
mais qu'on parle emploi si
c'était sensé plus que ça même par un
conseiller c'est être 200 ne peut pas
faire le même métier c'est pas possible
ils n'ont pas les mêmes moyens nos prix
sont aussi calculé montfaucon vivront
soit vivant une structure des locaux et
nos coûts sont calculés sur des
statistiques qui font que voilà c'est
rentable mais c'est inenvisageable de
transférer sa tel quel dans une
institution
nationale fin c'est bien c'est même pas
la peine d'y penser non plus y penser au
coût horaire c'est pas faisable
hervé ça prend entre 100 à 200 personnes
prises en charge et un conseiller pôle
emploi ici on est entre eux ou telle 20
et 30 25 maximum 30 permis parmi les les
fausses idées qui ont prévalu à la
création de pôle emploi il y avait
effectivement je rappelle juste la
fusion assedic m voilà il y avait eu
l'idée que chaque collaborateur qui
suivaient les demandeurs d'emploi aurait
dans son portefeuille je reprends le
terme à peu près 60 personnes 60 bon
aujourd'hui c'est toujours pas atteints
sauf dans quelques rares exceptions
c'est de l'ordre de 80 à 100 oui face
quand je disais que quand vous êtes dans
le 16e arrondissement de paris je prends
paris alors vous êtes dans cette
fourchette là mais à tremblay-en-france
vous arrivez alors quand elle ajoute je
serai malheureusement à ce que vous
dites que
ça c'est la moyenne nationale c'est pas
toujours le mieux répartie c'est à dire
que là où il y en a
le moins besoin c'est peut-être là où il
ya le moins de portefeuille chargé bon
ça c est donc
ça c'est le comment c'est le un point
très important et ce qui est dit dans le
documentaire est vrai jamais pôle emploi
n'arrivera à voir des pauvres de
feuilles de 30 demandeurs d'emploi sauf
à multiples enfin à faire 20%
d'effectifs en plus je rappelle
simplement le budget de pôle emploi à sa
création était de 3 milliards
aujourd'hui il est de 5 milliards il
devait se faire à effet à budget
constant est donc donc pour vous cette
fusion a été un échec en gros on
n'aurait jamais dû fusionner
moi je pense qu'on paye cher quelque
chose qui pour au mieux elles mêmes
performances qu'avant oui gérard filoche
safran compte et ça ça a été pointée de
nouveau par la cour des comptes au mois
de juillet que l'efficacité de pôle
emploi était quand même pas terrible
puisque l'organisme public ne serait à
l'origine de la reprise d'emploi que
dans 12 % des cas la 5 milliards pour
12% marais ces chiffres le sont
stupéfiants mais plein de pouce alors
après monsieur dix et quelques petites
dizaines de voix là et ensuite monsieur
concède quand même indirectement que
dans certains endroits on peut avoir
jusqu'à 260 way demandeur d'emploi très
large et sur un agent donc est ce ça
marche pas
ce pass donner les moyens ou alors c'est
parce que vraiment on a décidé qu'on
ferait
je n'arrive pas à comprendre avec 5
milliards de budget qu'on ne replace que
dans 12 % des cas ça me semble
absolument horatio absolument improbable
enfin c'est à dire que pôle emploi pour
moi c'est une réponse administrative un
problème économique bon c
fausse bonne idée
aujourd'hui il faut s'interroger
pourquoi les entreprises aujourd'hui
crée entre guillemets du chômage je
pense que c'est tout un cheminement que
n'a pas fait le gouvernement actuel que
n'a pas fait françois hollande après
avoir tapé sur les entrepreneurs taper
sur les entreprises après je dirais
avoir diabolisé les chefs d'entreprise
on s'étonne qu'aujourd'hui le chômage va
croissant mais prenons des solutions
essayant d'aider les entreprises
simplifions modernisons le droit du
travail je vais faire bondir monsieur
filoche
enfin du fameux rappeur combrexelle on
se dit voilà enfin du rapport
combrexelle pour être clair avec moi
téléspectateurs c'est le rapport a été
remis et donc par la direction générale
du travail à manuel valls il ya quelques
jours voilà enfin les bonnes questions
qui sont posées et puis on se dit
malheureusement le gouvernement actuel
ne va pas apporter les bonnes réponses
ça va être finalement un feu de paille
alors qu'il y a enfin l'entreprise qui
est remise alors au centre dont il a en
fait pour vous le problème du plafond
d'emploi c'est
les modalités de fonctionnement des
marchés du travail on n'a pas de
problème avec pôle emploi donc il y à du
problème avec pôle emploi j'assimile
d'assaut si je reprends les termes des
chaperons et chacun devient
problème faut pas réduire les
difficultés de rencontrer par pôle
emploi et il faut aider les entreprises
à se moderniser à avoir des de droit du
travail plus ou plus moderne et non pas
archaïque alors justement gérard filoche
parce que nous avons un droit du travail
archaïque est-ce que je ne sais même pas
pourquoi je vous pose la question est ce
que vous êtes convaincus par ce rapport
complexe une petite phrase quand même si
ça va mal et qu un million trois cent
mille chômeurs de plus depuis juin 2012
dans les catégories a et b c à baisser
leurs proches qu'il faut faire
gouvernement actuel s'est pas de dire
qu'il ne sait pas c'est de continuer la
politique que vous faisiez avant c'est
parce qu'il n'a pas rompu ab ce que vous
faisiez avant qu'on en est là bon
maintenant je vais vous du travail alors
le code du travail je dis à tout le
monde a toujours pas ce qu'on nous dise
yonne
le rapport nos cieux comme ericsson est
encore plus unis pour ceux qui s'y
exercent je leur conseille de lire les
44 mesures matin j'ai passé la venue sur
les calanques apprécieront le plus grand
d'une part une c'est ubu roi c'est à
dire qu'on peut à peine comprendre
chaque phrase sans avoir besoin d'une
explication de 20 minutes parce qu'elles
sont tellement caché masqué traître
qu'elle signifie bien d'autres choses
locaux du travail avait besoin d'être
écrit parce que ce congrès salle n'avait
déjà réécrit sous la droite madame de
2004 à 2008 entièrement c'est à dire que
ce qu au delà ils l'ont enlevée 10% 500
loi un livre sur neuf ils lui ont enlevé
un million cinq cent mille cinquante ans
non danon ordonnance de décembre 2004
promulguée par jacques chirac le 17 mars
2007 votée au sénat en 20 minutes
d'ailleurs pour 4 pour 994 pages format
a4 dans la nuit du 23 septembre 2007 à
l'assemblée nationale en huit ans le 4
décembre 2007 c'est rentré en vigueur le
1er mai 2008 était de tenir ça veut dire
que vous êtes
on n'a pas besoin de revoir le droit du
travail
le détruire et ensuite quand on est dit
il et il n'hésite par tous évidemment
les gens semblent où l'on montre
crawling
mais en vérité le code du travail c'est
le plus petit des codes voilà le voilà
c'est sans les commentaires il y fait
on dit attendez attendez toi 6 175 pages
de loi et où tous les autres codes de la
république sont beaucoup plus gros
pourquoi il apparaît comme ça parce qu'à
trois mille trois cents pages de
commentaires c'est comme si vous
habitiez françois salon a demandé par
marcel bon donc c'est de la triche alors
on triche pas quoi je pousse le code qui
n'est pas le vrai je monte le code avec
lequel on peut agir faire c'est un club
qui devrait davantage protégés contre le
licenciement tout simplement parce que
par exemple au licenciement est un droit
de l'homme vous savez madame c'est la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme de 1948 c'est la charte
européenne de 1990 de moi
je vous interromps un instant c'est un
moment pour remettre les gens dans
l'emploi quels sont les freins est ce
que effectivement le droit du travail
est ce que c'est un frein est-ce qu'il
faut pouvoir licencier plus facilement
est-ce qu'il faut pouvoir permettre
d'avoir plus de flexibilité sur ce
marché
trion qui sont les membres suivent c'est
aussi il faut d'abord freiné les
licenciements abusifs et boursier com en
scène fille pour vous parler des cadres
l'entreprise sanofi qui est absolument
resplendissante qui gagnent des
milliards se séparent dans autres sur
notre pays de 800 cadres de valeur parmi
les meilleurs chercheurs pour faire 4
milliards de bénéfices supplémentaires
ils s'en foutent des humains ils s'en
foutent de la production donc là on fait
les milliards vous attend on est dans
une mauvaise direction en train de que
si les employeurs pour parler des
entreprises mais les entreprises c'est
donc si on prétendait vivre les poissons
parce qu'il ya dans les poissons il ya
des requins il ya des requins et des
sardines alors ne mélangez pas les
petites entreprises et les grandes et
les grandes comme sanofi les grandes
comme sanofi c'est les donneurs d'ordre
donc c'est elle qui provoque y compris
par l'externalisation la masse de
chômage parce que ça les intéresse plus
de son carrelet à la finance que
d'embaucher ça les intéresse plus de
mettre l'argent les îles caïmans que de
produit
retardant les grandes entreprises de
notre pays aujourd'hui il ya un indice
qui est très précieux c'est le taux
d'utilisation des capacités productives
t ucp elles produisent à 70% vous vous
rendez compte de leurs capacités
c'est-à-dire qu'elle s'auto freine dans
la productivité parce qu'elles ne
peuvent pas vendre comme ils disent mais
elle met l'argent ailleurs alors si
elles ne peuvent pas avancer parce que
les gens peuvent pas acheter c'est un
promu le carnet de commandes et de
salaires donc
dernier alors qu'ils fêtaient le chômage
et provoquer je voudrais qu'on avance
sur le premier employeur en france si je
ne m'abuse ce sont bien les artisans les
très petites entreprises les moyens
d'entreprise on est d'accord sur la vous
me parlez
les chiffres que j'ai une entreprise de
plus de 1000 qui produit 50 % du produit
intérieur brut madame oui mais en terme
de nombre d'emplois rebelles font elles
font trois millions cinq cent mille
emplois seul si presque autant qu'un
million de moins de 10 comprenez c'est à
dire que les grandes entreprises
externalisent et son appel pmi-pme au
pays hôte est haute et in entreprises de
taille intermédiaire à 80% se souvenant
des entreprises sous-traitantes donc à
dépendre des donneurs d'ordre et c'est
comme ça qu'on nous masquer le transfert
à part par les décisions qu'ils ont
prises d'en haut qui à la fin fond du
chômage en bas mais qui font siphonner
l'argent qui remonte chaque fois qu'on
ait de l'entreprise pour qu'il aille en
eau et comme saclay ceux d'en haut
s'enrichissent et que ceux d'en bas
alors je voudrais donner la parole à
caroline cayeux a ses propres turbines
au jeu
très fidèle et je sais pas si elle est
apparue un peu vintage vous voyez ce que
je veux dire en terme l'analyse de
l'emploi ans il va foncer comme tout bon
je voudrais vous donner deux chiffres ce
que je ne sais pas si les
téléspectateurs se rendent compte que en
termes de compétitivité notre pays
depuis
l'e3 deux années des dernières sont
passées de la 27e place à la 32e place
mondiale de quoi pourquoi termes de
compétitivité gens n'ayant donné alors
qu'on a un
autre vous avez dû apprendre dans vos
livres d'histoire comme moi que la
france était la cinquième puissance
mondiale et bien subitement nous sommes
devenus la 6e et l'angleterre nous est
passé devant pourquoi pourquoi parce que
notre système de code du travail est
rigide il n'est aujourd'hui absolument
plus ou pas à jouer ces deux on a pas
tout à fait
rêver et n'est absolument plus adaptée
mais je disais tout à l'heure le rapport
qui nous a été sous qui a été soumis au
premier ministre iain il vient après un
rapport badinter monsieur filoche
badinter sur le droit du travail bien
sûr les autres il ya plein de belles
blondes il en est plein de décision
écrit un excellent mais
faudrait que moi je dis qu'aujourd'hui
il est urgent urgent de libérer les
entreprises de leur permettre d'être
compétitifs de l'adolescence y ait plus
sinon je n'ai jamais dit ça je pense
qu'il faut qu'il y ait une protection
des salariés protection des droits des
salariés mais néanmoins si les
entreprises arrivait à moduler le temps
de travail dans leurs entreprises comme
on le voit dans certaines entreprises
j'ai entendu parler l'autre jour d'une
entreprise qui fabrique des tracteurs et
bien il négocie semaine après semaine le
pendant ma vie en fonction des comores
vesa premier plan gagner moins
vous verrez supprimés et vous qui avez
supprimé les heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées
s'il vous plaît hervé chapron vous qui
semble-t-il avait une analyse fine de
ces freins à l'emploi en tant que
directeur enfin ancien directeur adjoint
de pôle emploi qu'est ce que vous avez
pu vous sur le terrain qu'est ce qui
était le plus compliqué en fait c'était
de convaincre les entreprises de faire
du cdi à la place du cdd c'était le
licenciement c'était quoi le cadre légal
notamment si la durée légale dramatique
en france c'est que vous avez que quand
vous reprenez votre ice et 85% de cdd en
flux pan stocks c'est à ce moment c'est
ce que c'est ça la différence non plus
et quand vous êtes embauché mais en
france aujourd'hui 85% des contrats sont
des cdi oui c'est même 95 % oui entre 29
ans
une entreprise et ne comprend pas cette
différence oui quand j'étais embauché en
cdd ouais mais enfin ces contrats mais
85% de céder à 97 % contre 29 54 ans que
les cdd sont artificiels parce qu'une
entreprise ne peut pas marcher avec des
cdd elle a besoin de la laver joindre du
rap vous aide à vous échappe êtes en
train de nous expliquer qu'il faut
donner des médecins ou bien portants moi
je parle de ceux qui sont en mauvaise
santé je parle donc que celui qui
retrouvent un emploi c'est 85% un cdd
mais parce qu'elles seront le volt ainsi
parce que c'est pas obligé parce qu'à y
en avait que réalise quand vous n'avez
quand vous avez un
moment qui n'est pas sûr qu'elle soit
renouvelée vous n'allez pas pourquoi il
ya bien sûr à 100 % de cdi c'est parce
qu'une les entreprises ont besoin d'une
main-d'oeuvre oise d'un suffit là je
vous dresse le plus année un exemple
simple un exemple qui va vous faire bon
film est un exemple simple et on en
entend parler tous les jours c'est le
travail du dimanche dans les zones à
paris alors les zones de la nationale n
aurait pas un seul emploi non attendez
attendez pour arriver à ça débat
parlementaire
quatorze mois
arrêt de loi loi qui finalement pas
promulguée
notre ministre macron
délimite les zones mal on se dit
attendez permettait compris qu'on se dit
ouf ça y est c'est fait et là vous avez
un recours gentiment bon c'est à dire
qu'on voit bien qu'il y a là une
rigidité face à une exigence monsieur
attendait cela fait marrer je ne vous ai
pas interrompu on voit bien là une
rigidité qui est d'abord de plusieurs
causes une régie tu es face à une
exigence économique parce que parce que
le monde est ainsi fait que les
étrangers qui arrivent en jet privé à
villacoublay et qui va aux galeries
lafayette dimanche il sait faire mais
ça va vous prendre trois cent mille
euros le dimanche marche à la prière des
chiffres depuis battre les autres jours
dimanche à moins de vente
ayant moins de
nous avons un aéroport dans notre ville
à beauvais d'un beauvais est bien quand
les gens intéressés qu'ils ont deux
trois quatre heures à passer il s'étonne
que dans une ville comme vous veniez pas
certain nombre de magasins en dehors des
commerçants de bouche comme à londres
comme dans d'autres villes d'où ils
viennent et je crois monsieur feuillage
que vous ne vous rendez pas compte que
le monde a changé et que nous sommes
dans une compétition mondiale qui fait
que notre pays aujourd'hui
moi j'ai mal pour la france alors je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on n'a pas pris les
bonnes mesures pour nous permettre
d'être re décoller une res cale de
longeville rapidement je voudrais vous
quelle est votre analyse quand vous
recevez donc ses cadres qu'est-ce qu'il
vous renvoie en fait des freins qui leur
permettent de revenir à l'emploi
les freins indiscutablement s'il
dynamisme août et économique il n'y a
pas de mouvements carnet de commandes
dont parlait alors du carnet de
commandes offre près on peut remonter
pourquoi les carnets de commandes sont
pleins cas patent il n'y a pas de
croissance c'est au débat enfin c'est
vrai que ça crée pas de la confiance du
dynamisme donc à peu d'opportunités du
coup conséquences de sa le marché est
étroit et compétitif les entreprises ont
du coup ont tendance à mettre des tas de
critères lorsqu'elles ont un besoin et
voir je vais d des contrats précaires ou
si il faut il faut pas il faut pas
l'écarter parce que les entreprises ne
sont pas sûres d'elles elles ne savent
pas si alors et demain l'activité sera
alors êtes vous
voudrez pas elle a créé des différences
entre les grandes entreprises ont parlé
gérard filoche tout à l'heure qui font
peut-être des licenciements boursiers et
les petites et moyennes entreprises qui
créent ce tissu d'emploi proxy d'eau de
proximité sur les entreprises sous
traitantes soit aligné le temps de la
mission sur la convention collective du
donneur d'ordre c'était faut pas que ça
soit l'occasion d'avoir une main
d'oeuvre moins chère moins payés et plus
restreinte vous collez les autres les
entreprises sous traitantes soit aligné
au centre protection du loup et du
travail et que l'on facilite le le
regroupement des groupes qu' il n'y ait
pas chez des nantais l'entreprise
cinquante six entreprises qui n'ont pas
les droits voulais juste vous dire que
ma soeur dimanche parce que ça a été
très long tout ce qui été dit tout à
l'heure que je suis en photo ne
comprends mais pour des raisons simples
c'est que le travail le dimanche va
faire perdre des emplois la cgpme
vindicte considérations générales 300000
emplois en moins dans les multi de
boutiques
par ailleurs ceux qui sont embauchés le
dimanche ne sont pas le lundi ensuite ce
qui sera vendu le dimanche ne le sera
pas le lundi parce que notre
portefeuille n'est pas prêt donc on perd
il valait ça on va donner eux c'est vrai
à des femmes pourrait prêter à des
étudiants désargentés l'occasion de
travailler le dimanche mais au détriment
d'autres emplois et pas pour augmenter
le chiffre d'affaires qui dans les
galeries lafayette ont été cités et plus
bas le dimanche que les autres jours
donc dont le dimanche n'apporte pas
d'emplois et donc que des résistances se
s'instaure moi je mets les tous les
jours pour qu'on arrête travailler le
dit malheur et chaque fois qu'on verra
filage que gérard gérard filoche chambas
à revoir ici un débat sur le travail du
dimanche juste en amont dites moi oui ou
non on voit bien qu'il ya qu'il 4,4 pour
cent des cadres qui sont au chômage
contre 20 pour cent des ouvriers non
qualifiés en gros ce qui nous protège le
plus du chômage c'est le diplôme
finalement pas rejoindre la formation la
formation la formation bien sûr je suis
pour l'apprentissage doit prendre son
tissage est une clé heureux aujourd'hui
oncle noël on vend bien et on voit bien
la réussite de l'allemagne qui a dansé
moyenne économie de l'eau la notion
d'apprentissage la formation il avait en
lui même pour les cadres et cadres
supérieurs à l'apprentissage à 14 ans
15 ans et demi qui est tombé d'une
échelle et un haut de 14 ans qui a été
broyée dans un pétrin je trouve les gars
ont mené des raids à travailler avant 16
ans et après notre bon tissage encore
faut-il bien de payer parce qu'il
commence à 25 % du smic wen à 85% du
smic qui fait que deux jeunes sur trois
ne le terminer il faut donc l'aura bien
payé mais bien très bien formés merci
beaucoup à gérard filoche merci beaucoup
caroline cayeux hervé chapron parce
qu'elle le longeait le pauline frachon
pour son documentaire merci de nous
avoir suivis bien entendu vous pouvez
toujours réagir sur le hashtag d'occuper
docu débat pardon à la semaine prochaine
on se retrouve ensemble une fois de plus
pour un débat sur l'identité nationale
vaste programme ciao
ouais